hello everyone and welcome back to the
magnus crossing invitational this is
game four of the match for the third
place wesley saw versus magnus carlsen
uh and uh
it's uh quite a short one so again uh
without further ado let's check it out
wesley has the white pieces uh and he
opens with e4
we have e5 by magnus knight to f3 uh we
have knight to c6 and bishop the c4
sorry about that uh we have bishop to
see
five by magnus and wesley of course goes
for the evans gambit he plays b4
yeah no no he doesn't he plays c3 of
course he goes for the
uh for the main line of the joko piano
that we have uh
knight to f6 by magnus and now d3 so
playing
very solid we have d6 by magnus and
knight b to d2 now so this has all been
seen before nothing out of the ordinary
uh we have castles and now h3 not
allowing bishop to g4
we have a6 by black and now bishop back
to b3
uh we have bishop to e6 magnusson offers
a trade of dark square bishops and
this is only uh to make sure he gets a
very strong center if
wesley captures then he gets a semi-open
uh f-file for the rook he gets
uh support for pushing d5 at some point
but wesley doesn't allow this he pushes
bishop to c2
and now what does magnus do well what do
you do when your opponent allows it
you play d5 so this is exactly what he
does we have d5
makes sense as uh you don't want to have
that backward spawn and also white's
king is still in the center of the board
you you want to attack it
uh wesley goes knight to g5 here and
it's interesting that um
wesley already had this position in the
tata steel tournament last year
against vishwanathan anand and the west
was able to win that game
uh but the end of the game we should
continue with the captures on e4 but
here magnus
just retreats with the bishop he plays
bishop to c8
and this is now a new move so already as
of move 10 we have a completely new game
and it seems that magnus is
was able to surprise wesley by finding a
move uh
in a very top tier game uh that that
wesley won uh uh
last year against thailand so let's see
how wesley deals with this uh
he captures on the e5 we have queen
captures on d5 and now wesley castles
it definitely makes sense or the the
black pieces are
closer and closer to the white king and
also the g2 pawn is hanging so here
white castles
and bishop to f5 now magnus going for
some very rapid development here
knight d to e4 uh and now comes bishop
back to e7 magnus doesn't want to allow
uh this trade knight for bishop so
bishop to e7 preserving both of the
bishops
and queen to f3 now now with a nice
trick if knight captures an f6 with
check then wesley picks up a carlson's
queen here on d5
so queen back to d7 and now b4
and grabbing more space here on the
queen side we have rook 8 to d8 by
magnus
and now rook to d1 uh rook to d1 now the
bishop can also move the d3 pawn is
nicely defended
uh and here comes uh okay although
instead of rook to d1 you you could have
gone for knight captures on f6
seems to be a bit of a safer move and
after bishop captures
knight e4 but wesley decided to go for
rook to d1
instead and now magnus plays the very
very interesting knight to d5
now what do you play here the c3 pawn is
hanging and you don't want to give it up
for nothing so here wesley pushes d4
now the queen defends the c3 pawn and
it's a very
tricky position for example if you go
for e captures on d4
then we get this amazing uh knight to c5
with
an attack on the queen and here magnus
would have the opportunity to actually
sacrifice the queen with bishop captures
on c2
for example knight captures rook
captures and now
uh you have this very very unpleasant
choice of giving
up the exchange or allowing d captures
on c3 and this will be just a monster
pawn on c3
so here best would be to just capture
that knight captures attacking the queen
see captures and now bishop captures and
before we would get this position where
magnus would have two rooks
a bishop pair in the night against the
queen rook uh knight and bishop
and black would would definitely have
the compensation here
uh but maybe it's not all that all that
much so instead of going for this magnus
just retreats we have bishop back to g6
and now wesley trades on e5 we have d
captures on e5
knight captures on e5 and now queen to
g3
uh putting pressure on that knight on e5
we have knight to c4
now getting that knight even closer uh
could be a bit dangerous because the
queen is still
occupying this this d7 square but
uh it doesn't appear to be a problem uh
wesley starts pushing the h
pawn now the knight is defended this
knight can now move
but now queen to c6 magnuson pins and
now this knight can move
so what do you play here here uh it's
very hard to find a move for
uh for wesley there are a couple of
moves like rook to e1 getting the rook
away from the d
file bishop to b3 maybe but wesley
played
rook to d4 and this move simply will not
do
but it's not all that easy to exploit
magnus took his time definitely so i
suggest you do as well
uh feel free to pause the video and find
the winning idea for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
spotting knight captures on b4 and yes
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show that's exactly what you have to
do here
knight captures on b4 and this just wins
on the spot the problem is
uh everything is hanging here uh the
rook is hanging
if you capture of course the knight then
black just captures the rook there's
of course no that's not the way to go
if you capture something else if you
capture on c4 you could give up the
exchange it doesn't really help you just
queen captures on c4 and once you
capture the knight the queen also picks
up the bishop on c2
so that also doesn't help so here
instead after rook to d4
uh after this knight captures on uh b4
uh
wesley decided to go for the only thing
left and that's rook captures on the
eighth threatening rook capture
signified with
check but now magnus plays knight
captures on c2 and now wesley's a1 rook
is hanging but still
rook captures and f8 comes with check
bishop captures on f8 and
now rook to b1 uh wesley gets the rook
out of harm's way
uh but uh you know that doesn't really
work bishop captures on e4 magnus wins
another piece knight captures queen
captures
and he was in this position unmoved 25
that magnus carlsen
uh wins the game or rather wesley still
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so there are two swift victories for
magnus
in the semi-final uh in the uh well
match for the third place
and we'll see what happens tomorrow if
he if he can uh
you know uh take it all the way so here
you resign because
uh well you're just down material uh
black has two pieces for a rook and
there's just not all that much you can
do once the knight moves
the rook will hang uh you don't really
have a good move if the rook moves then
something like 21 check followed by
capturing the bishop also bishop to d6
is coming
uh there's not there's no playing this
if f3 attacking the queen just queen d3
again with all the same ideas for
example if bishop to f4 there's even
knight to d4 even that is in the
position just attacking the rook
also threatening knight to e2 with a
nice royal fork here
and after rook to e1 defending against
this just 92
check and that's it you have to give up
your well
only remaining source of counter play
and then black is just up a piece and
completely winning
uh so after this queen captures on e4 uh
with the resigned and magnus wins the
the first match
uh so uh really really uh a nice one
uh it seems that magnus had a uh quite
quite a better day than he did yesterday
but uh yeah wesley wesley did give him
uh quite quite a few opportunities but
it's you know it always happens when you
don't go for the evidence gambit you
should always go for it uh
otherwise you're gonna lose like this uh
so yeah now we're gonna check out uh
some of the other games uh from the from
the main event anish geary versus yanni
pognishi but
the the the there weren't really any
decisive
uh results uh in in that match so i'm
gonna show one
one game from that match up tomorrow as
uh one of them was
kind of uh kind of uh well uh a feisty
one
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank andrew
sabach and norm tremblay uh william
gould uh shivan mahajan and adriad
sifico
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the magnus
cross and invitational
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
only now i've realized that my board for
some reason is not
properly centered uh happens sometimes
when i guess
chess.com updates uh the interface or
something like that so
uh i will align it uh the the video is
actually over but if any of you want to
check out how
how i'll align it that's perfectly fine
uh yeah this is how we do it there we go
all right
that should be perfectly aligned all
right so
thank you all and i will see you soon